welcome back to cbs this morning
canadian prime minister justin trudeau
is apologizing to indigenous canadians
after the remains of more than 200
indigenous children
were found last week some were as young
as three
many from indigenous communities
gathered this week to honor the lives
lost
the remains were discovered in kamloops
british columbia that was what was once
canada's largest residential school
for indigenous children our national
correspondent jerica duncan spoke
with a survivor jerica good morning good
morning this is such a dark chapter of
history
for canada that needs to be told the
kamloops indian residential school in
british columbia
used to have at least 51 confirmed
deaths on its official record
sadly one survivor told us he was not
surprised to find out at least 215
more students were found buried there
sometimes kids would not show up in
classroom
they would disappear for the next day
and
we knew that they were gone but we
didn't know where they were gone gary
gottfriedson is a survivor of the
kamloops indian residential school
he's among the thousands of indigenous
peoples legally mandated by the canadian
government
to attend such institutions they were
set up in the late 1800s and often
operated by the catholic church
the last one closed in 1997. university
of alberta professor
crystal gail fraser says abuse was
rampant
the whole point was to erase
their indigenous identities these indian
residential schools have often been
compared
to prisons we were never allowed to
speak our languages in there
because fear of punishment so
those of us that were little were
absolutely terrified
a truth and reconciliation commission
was formed to investigate abuse
at the indian residential schools in
2015 it issued a report saying the
government committed cultural genocide
at least 4 000 students died at these
schools
some of disease neglect accidents or
abuse
prime minister justin trudeau saying
sorry for the tragedies of the past
is not enough it is not enough for the
children who died
for the families or for the survivors
and communities
the heinous discovery happened after one
of the canadian first nations
used radar technology on the ground near
the school
indigenous communities and families have
been saying these things
for decades often not notified of deaths
their children never return home unable
to get any sorts of answers
in a statement that first nations chief
wrote the true accounting of the missing
students
will hopefully bring some peace and
closure to those lives lost
as for god frieden he's still haunted by
the memories
we were made to feel ugly because we
were told we were ugly
we were made to feel like we were
nothing but dirt
and that has remained with me to this
very very day
it's it's you know i've never felt that
i was good enough for anything
the canadian government has paid more
than 1.6
billion dollars to survivors of these
schools that 2015 commission recommended
94 calls to action
to help the country address its past
treatment of indigenous children
indigenous communities are now calling
for other school sites to also be
searched
for remains of school children just that
phrase remains of school
children it's a horrific situation but
this truth and reconciliation committee
is interesting it's an idea that has
been tried in other countries
not here though yeah trica thank you
very much